nous sommes ici dans l'un des barres de
Kiev bondées pour cette finale de la
Coupe du monde ils ont pu venir ici les
Ukrainiens regarder cette finale parce
que ce soir il y a de l'électricité
malgré les nombreuses coupures de
courant qui restent aléatoires à cause
des bombardements russes alors pour eux
le fait de se rassembler ici ce soir
c'est aussi une façon de dire non à la
guerre
il faut bien se changer un peu les idées
parce que si on ne décroche pas de ce
qui se passe chez nous le système
nerveux peut lâcher on peut devenir
dingue il faut savoir prendre du bon
temps
au Lexy et ses amis sont des combattants
il a été blessé au printemps dans la
région de Laurence
en permission ils sont aussi des fans de
football de la première heure alors ce
soir pour eux le moment est vraiment
particulier je me sens super bien je
suis ici avec ma famille mes amis mes
frères d'armes je suis bien je suis fier
pour mon pays la Russie doit savoir que
l'Ukraine résistera et vaincra
inévitablement
grosse ambiance lorsque l'Argentine
remporte le match au fur et à mesure du
jeu cette ambiance la cessé de monter
une chose est sûre c'est que le temps de
cette finale de la Coupe du monde les
Ukrainiens ont pu oublier un peu la
guerre